[Music]
emotional intelligence also known as EI
or EQ is the brain's ability to see
feelings coming and then to use them
listen to what they've got to say and
manage them
effectively people with lots of EI
recognize their own emotions and can
identify them in others this allows them
to discern between different feelings
adjust their inner states and
communicate
better perhaps the most relevant model
of emotional intelligence was developed
by the psychologists John Mayor and
Peter salave who defined it in 1990 as
the sum of four skills perceiving using
understanding and managing
emotions perceiving emotions is our
ability to detect them in faces pictures
and voices including in ourselves it's
the foundation of emotional intelligence
and makes all other processing of
sentimental information
possible using emotions is the ability
to align our hearts with our heads
people who are emotionally intelligent
can perceive their changing moods and as
a result may change what they do to
channel their feelings
effectively understanding emotions is
our ability to comprehend the complex
relationships between fear ings it
involves recognizing and describing how
moods evolve and change over
time managing emotions is the ability to
regulate feelings in ourselves and in
others people who are good at that can
control their sentiments manage their
moods and are able to influence the
emotions of
others while some people seem to be
naturally gifted with all four abilities
others have to work hard on every every
single one of them the good news is most
of us can improve our EI through
mindfulness exercises therapy and
education and it seems it's worth the
effort higher emotional intelligence
often correlates with higher academic
and professional success this is because
our emotions and the way we manage them
impact directly on our brain's ability
to listen and
learn and as Peter salv concluded people
in Good Moods are better at inductive
reasoning and creative problem
solving so what do you think is
emotional intelligence something we can
and should try to teach in schools and
if so how tell us your thoughts and
experiences of improving your own EI in
the comments
below
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit Sprout
schools.com